- So check this out.
You guys are both athletes.
So I read this great
article, and it was talking
about how athletes are
able to deal with pain
unlike regular people.
Non-athletes cannot deal
with pain the way athletes--
So it's real.
Because I was suspecting
that was true,
But you're saying that the
research verifies that.
Research vers it out.
And so because I know that
you're an athlete, I--
- In my day, in my day,
- In your day.
Well, yeah.
Well, I'm just
going to continue.
Next to me, you are an athlete.
- OK.
All right.
So there's a little thing
called the pressure test.
You know what the
pressure test is, right?
So you stick your hand
in a bucket of ice.
NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON: Yeah.
And most people can only
do that for, I don't know,
maybe 30 seconds
before the pain that
is associated with
the cold causes
you to pull your hand out.
Because you can't
find the last Budweiser
at the bottom of the--
[laughter]
CHUCK NICE: Which is how I--
Beer drinkers are good
at this, presumably.
CHUCK NICE: That's right.
OK
CHUCK NICE: So I wanted to
see if your resistance to pain
was any higher than a regular
person's resisting to pain,
and that would be me.
Oh, so what, are you going
to punch me in the face?
CHUCK NICE: So I
have a bucket of ice.
Come here.
NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON: Oh, you're
going to do the ice challenge.
Yes, I have it right here.
Oh!
Hey.
Simmer down.
- Oh, you have two, we have two.
- Oh!
One for each of us.
Fantastic.
Oh!
OK, I can tell you already
I don't want to do this.
[laughter]
All right, let me get a thing
out, you know what I mean.
You're going to
get an arm out?
So the idea is you stick
your hand in the ice,
and the first person
who pulls it out
is the person who has the
least resistance to pain.
I got a feeling that will
be me, because I stub my toe
and I call out of work.
[laughter]
All right.
So we just do this.
CHUCK NICE: Yes.
OK.
CHUCK NICE: And we can
continue on with this show.
Right, right.
Because I can't wait
around for this.
Right.
Are you ready?
OK.
Let me get mine a little closer.
CHUCK NICE: Yeah, and
I'll get mine over here.
All right.
OK, but I got to
continue to show.
OK.
We can continue the show.
NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON: OK.
Ready?
Three, two, one, go.
So here's something
interesting.
Athletes--
I have to pee.
--they sit in ice baths.
They sit in ice baths
to-- you know, pitchers.
You were a pitcher in baseball.
Didn't you ice
down your shoulder?
SPEAKER: Yes.
NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON: Yeah, OK.
[laughter]
(LAUGHING) Chuck,
what's the matter?
What's the matter, Chuck?
[laughter]
This is [bleep].
So is this mental
toughness here?
All right, that's it.
Oh my god.
NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON:
What is going on here?
Is it mental toughness?
[applause]
No, no.
Just to be clear, it's not
that this doesn't hurt me.
It's just that I'm OK with it.
You are a
dominatrix best dream.
[laughter]
NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON: OK.
[applause]